[Music]
when the young kids on the street found
out that i was working on star wars i
was like a god to them
those kids are now parents
they've seen the movies throughout the
years
there's always in the back of their mind
like oh wow i remember playing with the
falcon i remember playing with the
x-wing and the tie fighter
to understand
that you have a small part of that kind
of bigger world
is is pretty cool
[Music]
my name is mark boudreau and i've been
fortunate enough to work on star wars
toys since 1977.
amazing thing about star wars i don't
think it's really ever gone away it's
always been there vehicles has been sort
of what i really am the most passionate
about
tie fighters
x-wings a raised speeder
i've always built models built planes
cars so they said hey mark why don't you
go ahead and start working on the
millennium falcon i said like sure why
not
[Music]
i'm laying falcon is more than just a
machine
it really is a character that helps save
the day it's more than just a hunk of
junk
he wanted to be able to provide an
experience that could extend from the
film so when you went to go see the
movie you come right back and you're
playing with luke you're playing with
han you're playing with chewie and
you're able to relive everything that
you saw on the film
long after i've gone to the forest
wherever that might be
this product will still be there
[Music]
grandkids from now
will hopefully still be enjoying star
wars and we certainly want to try to do
our small part into making sure that
that continues
[Music]
it starts with a yes or no question does
she have a crush on me will i pass the
test will the mets win the world series
while they may not have always predicted
the truth magic 8 balls are actually
inspired by a real-life clairvoyant
do you want to hear your fortune
in the 1940s mary carter was a popular
medium best known for her mysterious
fortune telling invention it was called
the psychoslate essentially a chalkboard
with a cover when the clients would
visit mary would ask a question to the
spirits
the room would fill with the sound of
scribbling and then just like poof magic
mary would reveal answers from another
world mysteriously written on the
chalkboard
mary's son albert was inspired by his
mother and created his own truth-seeking
device but this time you didn't need a
psychic to tell you your fortune
he put a pair of worded dice inside a
tube filled with molasses each end was
clear so you could read the answers
sound familiar
albert hit the streets he partnered with
a couple local businessman and opened a
novelty company where they specialized
in the miracle home fortune teller after
he died albert's partners took over and
redesigned the project numerous times
they ended up with a crystal ball like
shape with a die in the middle and a
billiards company took note they needed
a promotional item so they replaced the
crystal ball with the iconic black eight
ball
the promotion was so successful that
they rebranded the magic 8-ball this
time marketing it as a fortune telling
toy
today kids are still using magic 8-balls
to ask for their fortunes and for that
you can thank mary the clairvoyant
ah yes
[Music]
ralph waldo emerson once
quoted that
nothing great can ever be achieved
without enthusiasm
i have a lot of enthusiasm
[Music]
this is northlands in flemington new
jersey
northlands is the world's largest model
railroad
well i guess you know everybody has a
passion for something my thing was
trains had trains around the christmas
tree as a kid wherever i lived i'm
planning track plans and then over 18
years i added five basements onto the
house
from that i got fairly good at making
mountains and bridges and design work
and we decided to give it to the world
so we tore it all down bought this land
built northlands
any given day we run between 85 and 90
trains
some of the details in northlands inside
about forty thousand feet of track about
four thousand buildings
over four hundred bridges many of the
mountains in here are three and a half
stories high
most things in here are scratch built
underneath the entire superstructure
there's enough lumber to build about 42
large houses
takes a few hours to go through for the
average person
to see everything
we went millions into debt
to build this place everywhere i thought
we were nuts the only one that believed
that what i wanted to do was my wife and
she was totally with me on this big time
it's an artistic endeavor it's a gift to
the world of what i can do
and it makes
a lot of people
[Music]
when you happy people that i run a slot
car
they go what what's that
i never heard of that before
when they first do it they go wow
this is fun
i am buzz frank perry i am the
proprietor of buzzerama the slot car
racing center of the world
racing is a hobby sport that's
participated in all over the world
in 1965 it was my hobby i was one of the
first to open in new york
there was 48 places like this in the
city
today i'm in
i'm the lone survivor
they have 12 volt dc motors in them and
a guide flag that fits in slot and when
you hit the hand controller it energizes
those lanes
and gives the motor juice
the fastest cars
can go upwards of 100 miles an hour so
they're like blurs now you have to hear
them yo
you can hardly see them you have to
listen to them you go wow
kids play with computer now
and there's no interaction with anyone
over here they have an interaction
with other drivers they compete they
congratulate each other you learn
sportsmanship
it's really great just watching the cars
go around the tracks pumps up your
adrenaline and you get all excited and
that that thrill never leaves you
you always think about it
silly string that bright fun party in an
aerosol can was actually invented by
mistake
believe it or not it was supposed to
help heal your broken bones
in 1972 leonard a fish and inventor and
robert p cox a chemist were granted a
u.s patent for a foamable resinous
composition
the two initially set out to create an
aerosol can that could spray an instant
cast on a broken leg or arm and the
invention worked
but when it came to packaging their
discovery they tested 500 different
types of nozzles through their tests
fish came upon one that produced a
string a string that shot 30 feet across
the room inspired they decided to turn
their instant cast into a toy
after altering the formula to produce a
more colorful less sticky string the
pair set out to market their product
neither of them knew the first thing
about selling toys so they made an
appointment with wamo in california
but the meeting didn't go exactly as
planned
fishing [ __ ] sprayed the string all
over the office including on the person
they were meeting with
and unsurprisingly get out they were
asked to leave the premises just one day
later fish received the telegram from
wemo asking him to send 24 cans for a
market test
turns out that a trace of the silly
string was left on a lampshade in the
office and was later spotted by wemos
owners who themselves demanded a market
test immediately
two weeks later guamo signed a contract
to license the product now known as
silly string
there's this amazing picture of my
co-worker it's him reading a ninja
turtles book lying next to a super
soaker
[Music]
when the super soaker came out it was a
game changer the slogan wetter is better
was essentially a mantra for kids during
summer break
so when i went to atlanta to interview
the guy responsible for all that i had
to show him the photo
[Music]
that's funny
lonnie johnson invented the super soaker
back in 1982
but that is not his only invention
well i have over 100 patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter he also
worked on nasa's galileo mission to
jupiter and alongside the us military
the first super circle actually i made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when i would come home from
work and at the time i was actually
working on the stealth farmer program
back when it was highly classified and i
actually couldn't even tell my wife what
i was working on during the daytime it
was that that top secret
the original name for the super soaker
was the drencher we ran into a challenge
uh regarding the name because another
inventor claimed it so we changed the
name to super soaker just to avoid
having to to deal with that super soaker
is definitely a way better name
when he started lonnie wasn't trying to
create a toy for kids i was working on a
new type of heat pump that would use
water as a working fluid instead of
freon
and i was experimenting with some
nozzles that i machined
and i shot a stream of water across the
bathroom and i thought she's maybe i
should put this hard side stuff aside
and work on something fun like a water
gun
it still works and this brings me back
to a previous point monty johnson is a
super genius scientist
this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
right now i'm working on advanced
maverick technology my goal is to
develop a battery that will store about
three times the energy of a lithium-ion
battery in comparison the super soaker
might not seem as hard science
but it was still a really really
important invention
[Music]
i'm the first woman to graduate with a
doctorate from juilliard
and now i play the toy piano
life works in mysterious ways
[Music]
i have transformed the toy piano into a
real instrument
to play the toy piano well
you have to practice on it every bit as
hard as you would
on a normal piano in fact i think you
have to work even harder because the
action is so primitive
you can make it sound beautiful you can
make it sound convincing
it's a bit like going down the rabbit
hole
and taking your audience with you
way back
down this avenue
to your childhood days
[Music]
once
a skeptical person
comes to a toy piano concert that i give
i'm able to turn him around
it's
a whole
extended family now of people
into toy pianos it's a fearless
little band who are willing to stick
their necks out for toys
[Music]
[Music]
you